buenos dias santiago si efectivamente
como lo decís el día de ayer escuchamos
las posturas que prácticamente se
esperaba no respecto de los mandatarios
que fueron oradores en este marco del
aniversario número 75 de las naciones
unidas- vimos dos ramas claramente
divididas esta atención de la que
también hablabas al principio por un
lado escuchamos a estos dos mandatarios
internacionales que claramente
representan ese populismo de derechas el
corrosivo nacionalismo muchas veces la
soberbia ellos son por supuesto
bolsonaro y el presidente de donald
trump
trump por un lado que pide ala y
solicita a las naciones unidas que hagan
rendir cuentas a china por infectar al
mundo con el coronavirus es un reclamo
totalmente válido absolutamente pero
cabe que nos preguntemos también qué se
puede esperar de las naciones unidas- un
organismo que de hecho hoy día sigue
llamando excelentísimo presidente a
nicolás maduro no que sabemos bien lo
que representa con su con su régimen a
lo largo del hemisferio y por otro lado
vimos también el discurso del presidente
de jair bolsonaro de brasil dentro del
ala también de estos populismos de
derechas quien también señaló no es la
responsabilidad de china en los sucesos
de este año y por otro lado dijo y lo
cito textualmente que la libertad es el
mayor activo de la humanidad de eso sí
como siempre bolsonaro sin mencionar que
para él se trata de algunas libertades
no que para él las libertades se dividen
en tajos y esto lo digo porque bien
sabemos que no está a favor ni de la
legalización de las drogas también
sabemos sus posturas claramente
homofóbicas que dejan en evidencia el
fuerte conservadurismo que carga este
tinte de populismo de derechas sin lugar
a dudas pero con con posturas bastante
controversiales ambos y con al menos por
parte del presidente de jair bolsonaro
en el brasil donde recibió muchas
críticas al respecto de su discurso en
las naciones unidas
antonio la nos queda poco tiempo menos
de un minuto pero no quiero dejar de
preguntarte cómo evaluar la
participación de américa latina' no
considera
se dejan de lado en esta oportunidad
ciertas tensiones regionales por el tema
de la pandemia que unifica de los
problemas de la región sin lugar a dudas
yo creo que si se están dejando de se
están dejando de lado ciertos aspectos
que refieren a la coyuntura también del
día a día de américa latina- hemos visto
también una jornada de este aniversario
número 75 de las naciones unidas-
bastante eclipsado por esta atención
entre los eeuu y china
también bueno hemos visto el
discurso encabezado por jinping que está
al mando de este régimen comunista china
chino quien dijo al mundo que necesita
solidaridad y confianza y es un
comentario yo creo en que carga bastante
sarcasmo lo tenemos que decir recordemos
que al comienzo de la pandemia el
régimen chino escondió el coi 19 desde
el primer día y reprimió a los doctores
que investigaban al virus en china pero
si efectivamente santiago antonella
martín muchísimas gracias por estos
minutos con france24 ha sido un placer